well upon death what are the problem
that we are trying to solve I don't know
how many of you are familiar with
stumbleupon door I've used stumbleupon
but stumbleupon is a quite old startup
in the sense that was founded 11 years
ago for solving a problem then no one
was solving and this problem was
serendipity search after 11 years no one
is still solving the problem of
serendipity search not big players are
doing not Google not being not yahoo why
because it's an extremely difficult
problem what serendipity pro search is
about is basically the user come to
stumbleupon without a clear information
need it's not that you come and you say
I want to find the address of trulia in
San Francisco you and working for many
years Yahoo it is clear in the most of
the case what the user want and this
clear how to set up relevance
measurements and is clear to say okay
the user was successful the user was not
successful in full field is information
need with 13 deputies searched DS does
not happen the user arrived and want to
find the information but in a fashion
that is more similar to be entertained
so we still need to present the user
with information that is relevant to the
user but we don't have any clue about
what is really relevant to the user we
have broad interest categories but
within an interest you can really bro
such
number of different facet a different
aspect the other big problem of
discovery of trendy BTW search is that
we present one result at the time so all
is good the user likes o is not good
there is no other you no other way to do
in search the effect is not so direct
the user has at least 10 result you can
choose from and so even if the result is
not the first result but is the third
result it still can be happy it still
can find what he was looking for trendy
be searched never repeats you never see
well there are bugs but in theory you
never see the same page twice and so
this means that we needed to carefully
select pages and do with the dub
detection in order not to show you page
that are very very similar and if you
think about news in which usually you
have until that is repeated from many
different website this is extremely
different difficult the other important
part of serendipity searches that needs
to adapt if you come back a result the
page I need to be sure that next time
that you search in that particular
interest I'm not showing you similar
results that you can consider not
relevant your experience search this
doesn't up and the proof of these I mean
we know we have the static results
search and in the most of the case
people is using search I think that was
around ten fifteen percent of the
queries are used as a bookmarking tool
so they don't don't save the address of
truly anywhere they just search again
and this is kind of boo marking and
obviously discovery needs serendipity
search in this case needs to be personal
needs to be very tailored to you so we
needed to provide different result if
you are young if you are old if you are
female male and some result that target
for people basically located in San
Francisco maybe are not so good for
people that is located on the east coast
and so far so as I told you I don't
think that currently there is any big
player let's speak about big player
google but you can correct me or you
being yahoo that i have tried
successfully to solve trendy pity search
problem i'll stumble upon works there
you come on the side you register weed
email and password with your facebook
account second important step you need
to select interest and it is like down
teeth step because we have 523 interest
that's it you start stumbling one at a
time just you hit the ball continues and
what we hope we hope that to basically
take a big portion of the time that
users spent on internet for i would say
not work-related time and is very
difficult when stumbleupon started
facebook twitter pinterest ready worth
guy now we are
getting with the time that you spend
looking at the picture your friends or
tweeting about your personal life or
commenting about news work in another
similar network so it became difficult
and difficult every day more and more
but still we have user that are with
stumbleupon since day one they keep
stumbling they are loyal they come
almost every day and they keep enjoying
the the product how we do what we do
well this is a really broad overview but
we inject content we have two way to do
it one is by user discovery if you have
a favorite page you can submit it or
crawling subset of trusted source
obviously this change over time that we
have a number of filters some you you
know the goal is to select good content
other are just business rules or you
know try to understand if we have other
content and so there is a second phase
it is what we call sampling and the
sampling phase just try to solve the
same problem that all the recommendation
system have and is the cold start
problem well I do not have any
information about a page and they need
to understand how good is it I basically
we keeping it in this limbo for a
minimum number of stumble or a fixed
period of time and we basically monitor
out this page behave if
page pass the threshold of minimum
quality it becomes one of the page of
our index and we start recommending
according to our recommendation
methodologies so obviously at the center
of everything is the user and the user
tell us explicitly what you like so the
set of is interest and sometimes we see
that yet kind of favorite kind of news
or trending content versus I don't know
evergreen content for example you can
also choose a particular you know
keyword and this becomes kind of
channels we actually have channel but we
are going to discontinue them but we can
see that there are some source that they
use some channel that the user prefer
but also we suggest results on the base
of what friends do we have a similar
mechanism of following like twitter you
can follow a be followed by friends and
obviously suggesting what friends like
is one of the most common to duke thing
to do and at the end we add we have also
other implicit signal and that we
leverage and the tower like-minded user
so user that have similar interest
profile so the same selection of
interest or similar age similar gender
and also expert we have a methodology
algorithm if you want that allowed to
select the top user within each interest
and so we know that this user usually
submit discover content that is I
quality and will leverage
user for suggestion purpose what is the
business model obviously sponsored
stumbles why this model is successful
and it's a quite successful model I have
to say I think that so the the business
model is called native advertising what
is native advertising and why it's
different from other form of advertising
all the other form of advertising if you
think about a TV or display basically
interrupt the user experience what I
mean with this well that you're watching
a movie and you are stopped to see a
particular ads this is breaking your
user experience of watching a movie
display advertising is the same you are
reading news maybe politics and you have
a display of the car doesn't fit with
what you are reading in most of the
cases and so you have to you need to
switch from what you're doing to watch
and click on the adds this does not
usually happen as a usually obviously on
native advertised so the way is done is
another should be just another stumble
so in the ideal case user should not
realize that is not part of the user
experience for the only difference that
we have that sponsored mark on top of
the page and run advertis ads that are
particular that and in such a measure
that user like them Tom Bob's they share
ads and for
the advertiser did is particularly
successful because in the moment that
user likes or share this kind of piece
of content this becomes organic what I
mean with this is that this is injected
in our index and is served as the rest
of organic content so user advertiser
you can actually reach much number of
user for which they do not pay obviously
is not always easy to give user
experience to give the user experience
that is organic especially because we
have two different type of campaign one
is managed and for the managed campaign
we can and one is unmanaged so user can
actually submit whatever they want but
we reserve the right to show this
content or not if they so also also add
is in the limbo for a while if we start
collecting a lot of negative feedback we
can actually decide to stop showing that
because what weaker the most is still
the user experience as you can see here
for example the way is done they target
segment demographic segment in the most
of the case this is what show it to me
because I am a woman in a particular
segment in San Francisco probably but as
you can see what we appear here is an
article mistake that you do when you
take care of your skin so seems more
health that not selling you proud but of
course they want to send me some
products
as I told you this is an old startup and
it's a start in the sense of 85
employees but we have a user base of 35
million registered user a hundred
thousand advertiser and a size of the
index that is a hundred million page and
as a matter of fact tombola pony is the
fourth social media traffic generator we
actually generate more traffic than not
link it in the not google plus total war
stumble are on mobile platform and so
this is another challenge and again
number of employees a t5 if we consider
the the revenue per employee is I girly
not in Google and it's something to be
proud of what is the data science role
in this obviously we talked about 85
total employees into office New York San
Francisco engineering is in total I
think 30 30 35 and data science is I
also say me now it's a three person plus
a analytic engineer that is in charge of
the data pipeline three person that
needs to take care to support
data-driven bad word innovation
initiative or exactly for all istanbul
product and when i say some product i
mean male mobile site personalization
and romania and we actually are able to
do it with i would say good result
so I'm going to present now a number of
project we have done I'm not entering in
the technical details but if you have
questions of course you can ask I
thought that for a torque at 7pm you
really don't want to to be bother but
you can contact me and so the first to
use case are an example of how interest
can be exploited and why they are so
important and a third example is some
optimization that we have done for the
revenue team and I will briefly speak
about what else we are trying to do a
summer / so as I told you interests are
very important important for example for
an infographic point of view we can
actually see and understand how users
are using our product just look at what
they rate correct so we see for example
that teenager prefer natural relate
topic animals pet exotic animal but
surprisingly did for example rates top
rates also interest like mathematic or
writings so really teenagers likes
mathematics I don't think so i think
that they are using especially when you
have big number right they are using the
site to bookmark resources probably for
homework and so this is kind of
different that saying they're using
stumbleupon just for be entertained
winterton is still the most important
aspect of stumbleupon but looking at
interest we understand differences if we
look at women for example young women
for sure day rates I don't know
parenting babies kids more than men and
it is not surprising but
still they also for example rate
computer programming related stuff and I
don't think that this is again for
entertainment they probably took marking
some resources for that they find useful
for work so the problem of gender
prediction reading some you know
literature recently I found this recent
paper 2013 it actually analyze how they
the way people disclosure personal
information on the web is changing in
since 2005 and actually they notice that
there is a shift people is more
concerned now the not in 2005 about
disclosure personal information this
actually is from facebook they monitor
I'll change the quantity of information
that people is given about I school
uptown birthday interest so far so on
and so the blue is less dense the red is
a lot of more information and this is
the heat map how it goes in the last few
years another paper that i read recently
was 2010 actually give some numbers they
say the thirty percent of user do not
disclose the rage on facebook twenty
percent their gender and the ninety-five
percent political affiliation some upon
is not different from the rest of the
world but our number are a little bit
less we have that ten percent of
stumbleupon user do not declare their
gender at the registration time and age
is mandatory
you need to be 13 I think year old to
create an account of stumbleupon because
there is an adult content and so we but
zero-point-three percent of our user as
more than a hundred year and 0.4 percent
is in the 800 interval we are still
speaking about hundred thousand of user
what you can obviously in fear is that
you should not trust age in general so I
don't know why should trust a gender
either but let's say that we trusted
aide agenda obviously this is a problem
right we do not have so many ingredient
for a recommendation we have demographic
plus interest if we cannot trust
demographic we are left to us with
interest it's not enough and also
because targeting advertiser basically
come to stumbleupon and say I want to
target women that are in the segment
3446 and at live in san francisc if we
don't know the gender and we denote the
age it's kind of difficult to do the
appropriate behavioral targeting
targeting for ads so we need to
understand who are these ten percent of
the user to increase retention to
increase revenue and surprisingly and I
found a lot of literature related work
even reason to related work that trying
to solve the problem of gender
prediction there are some method that
just use link based information for
example in facebook and then for gender
just from the social network
there are some work that right to infer
gender looking at x 12 feature so if you
write it to it or if you write a comment
for a movie review for a movie I I can
do some processing on the language that
you are using and I can't tell if you
are man or if you are a woman a recent
paper is from guys from Technicolor
represent is the user gender based on
ratings so this was our axis 2012 and
they actually say just observing the
ratings on movies that is extremely
sparse we know that it is very sparse we
can say if you are a woman or a man with
a good result 86 is on flixster
eighty-four percent using logistic
regression and 86 using as we have
pretty good result is that okay that's
right we have interest our mother is
extremely simple what we did we just
look at the basket of interest one if
you user select the interests the
otherwise straight random forest we
physically train this model every night
on 0.1 percent of our users and
initially with test and fe be connected
the user for which we did not have an
information LC is 88 way I garden what
is not reported in literature for the
same problem just using interest
I'll see when we speak about machine
learning the data mining let's go back
to the company and let's try to explain
to the exact why this model is good and
his mother is good because of this if we
can actually target ten percent of the
user that we cannot target before the
estimation of increasing in revenue is
ten percent just with the simple
recommendation classification not so
interests are really powerful we use for
recommendation purpose we use for
understanding user so we need to give
the possibility to the user tools really
select the best interest for them right
and it is not always easy so I'm not
saying anything new when I state that
content that works on the web usually
does not work on a mobile device and you
said there are pages that are highly
optimized for mobile for the mobile
experience what about interested
selection on a mobile we have 523
interest so suppose that you are
creating an account on mobile and user
do they actually create account using
apps try to browse 523 interest with
your mobile obviously big bias we have a
lot of interest with a but artists
usually they interest that better
characterize that particular user so we
said okay we saw that interests are
powerful so given the interest we can
understand user what if given the user
we try to present them with
to interest for that but what we know at
and the moment that the user is creating
account we know the gender hopefully if
you said to us the age the device they
mail and at set and what we want to take
what is the metric that I want to try to
autumn eyes at this phase of
recommendation I want to optimize what
we call activation activation is what
tell us if for the user that created an
account is becoming a real user user
that will come back in seven day in 14
days in 30 days of a result possibly
loyal user we have good model to predict
if if user is activated there is a paper
presented at dub dub dub 2013 if you are
interested in see our activation matrix
and so we basically can say given a user
and given this information we can create
a data set in which say this user is
going to be activated is not big problem
we don't save interest we don't have in
our data the interest that user
basically saved a registration we see we
have in our tough at all IDI interest at
the current moment so and obviously as
part of the recommendation we present
the user with you like mathematic do you
want to browse also physic so we really
don't know what are they interested the
registration moment but we can consider
the interest in the very first session
for the user and try to use that to
understand which are the interest that
better behave on mobile we sample the
first session over a period of three
months so for session for each new user
and we try to see if we can apply any
classification framework if we can try
any model we tried a lot of you know
out-of-the-box methodology none of them
work coin is the best so what we did was
something a little bit different we have
the problem as an association troll
problem I think most of you are familiar
is quite use so we said okay let's see
let's track all the rules that say
interest humor activated equal one
interest kale steer it activated equals
zero and so far so we fix the minimum
support to fifteen percent the minimum
confidence to seventy percent and the
minimum left one point one percent in
this way we always pruned all the rules
with the same left side not indicative
right and as result of this first to two
step we were left with 80 interest that
are actually fifteen percent of the
total interest that we have so one
natural question will be but maybe it is
because user actually select only these
80 interest on mobile so we did a
comparison and we actually see that we
the cumulative distribution of interest
istanbul on mobile and on web toolbar
the website number website is mostly the
same so there is no such bias that only
80 interests are actually used on mobile
we did a second step and said okay at
this point we will use the demographic
information and we just ranked
days interest on the base of popularity
so Tom Bob's thumb down and so the
obviously the results are interesting we
as such a standard that we are going to
Abbott as this we could not because our
mobile system was not prepared to
dynamically select interest so the
interface was static so we could not
change the order but we added to wait
for front-end to do the necessary
modification but so this is a comparison
on the segment on two different device
one is android tablet the other is ipad
for men and woman under 24 year old can
you tell who is a man which column is a
man on android i could without looking
without knowing and this is because i
really think that there are some you
know think that we say about the
diversity or user android vs a user of
nye but it actually are true as a matter
of fact for sure you can say were the
women here the two column that are the
women and the two column that our men
and it's so evident these are less than
40 24 year old food cooking food cooking
no way that college male student is
going to browse cooking receive and they
are drawing and drawing only women will
then Droid guy here dan droid man come
on hacking it is then droid sorry
for it it is actually interesting what
is the thing that I noticed here I told
you that in the top rating interest on
the web i found that general teenager
also rates mathematics also rate a
physic or something that the writing
none of these interest is here because
obviously you are not going to do your
own work on a platform like this so if
you are so if you are a user that as is
signing with a mobile device your
purpose is mostly entertained so this is
totally different experience is a
totally different way of using
stumbleupon the not on mobile similarly
this is the top comparison for 46 / 46
year old now food cooking is over so
everyone eats after 40 60 then they want
well but you will see that women for
example there is held alt is something
that everything care there is no more
music anymore that was instead music
walls in the others wide but mins our
men are worried about health where is
the help instead women are worried and
want to browse alternative health they
really don't have any health problem
they just want to be alternative and
iphone ipad actually they want to travel
androidguys seems that they don't they
don't want so there are different that
actually the device itself android vs
ipod put in evidence and when you think
about are not so hard right
so it's so this is the last thing that I
want to talk kind in semi details and
after I want I have a just an overview
of other problem we are trying to solve
this is very fast so as I told you we
have two different way to do advertising
two different type of campaigns one is
the managed and the other is a day and
managed static price we don't have bid
we don't have any dynamic pricing is it
works so well that we don't need any
form of it optimization so far so but we
have a payment threshold so especially
for they manage campaign if the user
does not stay at least a four second we
are not going to get any money and
anything for seems like kind of
opportunity I mean if we have campaign
that we in any case we get money and
campaign for which we don't get money if
the user doesn't stay for at least four
second maybe we should try to optimize
and what we did was very simple
statistical analysis so what we did was
we simply compute the probability the
tendency of the user to skip what we
notice is that there are user that
naturally skip they actually especially
on mobile they skip skip that read just
the title and this is the way they
actually use not even if it's good or
bad they actually use the device like
this when we want to send advertise to
that oh if we want to send advertise to
them the one that does not have a
treasured for payment and the other
thing that we did
we filter the expected amount of money
to be made by serving a particular ads
with a particular treasure to the pair
user device then we rank these these
basically is happen every night and we
have this optimal selection of ads to
user on the base of their tendency to
skip as I told you obviously this model
works when we have a lot of that
especially for example in months like
December which we have the peak of
advertiser and all of them want to serve
a lot of ads in which the skipper eight
improved by seven percent and this means
in in the top week of December and net
gain of seven thousand dollar per day
justice understanding the tendency of
the user to skip this is the last I was
a last that I want to talk we are doing
other cool stuff ah we're doing a lot
for being a tree I think that we are
really avid trouble that is amazing and
they have to say I have I work I yahoo
for five years and the constant problem
that that was at scientist that there
was not data scientist at that moment we
were applied scientist some point I
became data scientist but the big
problem was they I would say the
limitation we never were were so fast as
engineering engineering was ready to
deploy next model and we still needed
time this is the first time that I
actually do not have this problem our
true put is either than not engineering
so we actually the ability to say I
deploying this I'm not going to
give you any support you have two other
two model other two algorithm to deploy
what we're doing and some could work the
first work we are actually trying to use
dual time to predict ratings we're doing
something very similar to this paper
with some 2014 so we actually still are
segmenting our items from the base of
interest and user behavior and we are
basically using a probabilistic model to
understand our toes distributed with
respect to rate current by the base line
with the random forest as an equivalency
of seventy five point seven but it is
our baseline this is a true an important
project is going to help a lot with a
cold start problem so as I told you we
have a limbo state which page are for 24
hour or minimum number of stumble but if
we don't reach enough rating in that
limbo period that the pages discard it
but what if since we didn't know
anything about the pay the page we've
just presented to the wrong user so the
idea is that we do not have time to
collect enough evidence even if the page
maybe is good this will help alot and
also to recommend so again
recommendation this is the
recommendation engine I like I don't
like but also all the recommendation
engine have the exactly same problem
ratings are sparse a model that actually
exploit dual time is not a sports model
anymore is the model for which you have
one vote for each item your index the
other project that we are doing is in
collaboration with Professor Saran and
professor dongle from the university of
santa clara and this is a we want to
predict the user
and this is a web app web product user
get bored and they live so we needed to
counteract so predicting user chart is
the the most natural thing to do we are
using this model from this paper
counting your customer one by one and
this model is basically is the consumer
behavior model and it's a base on
hypothesis of APIs on purchases and
exponential lifetime we have a basil
pretty strong we are adding coverage
correct means demographic or other
information about the user the idea is
that we will have kind of rate for each
user that is telling us this user going
to stay lawyer this user is going to
leave soon and obviously this will be
used for notification purpose so if I
have to select a number of users that I
want to send an email saying it look we
have them stream league good content for
you and also we start we haven't done
and i would say till this moment no work
on our social network so we have not
exploit leaders we are not to suggest
friends so we are starting will work on
us on this and this is not all but as i
discovered huge part what data science
means of tamil upon and thank you
you